Sì Guardate mi sono trasformato in treno
vieni qua Subito ora ti schiaccio dai
proviamo
subito dopo un'ora Benvenuti su Anita
Stories Raccontaci
che ci Trasformeremo negheremo presto
Insomma
mi piace e iniziamo subito e vediamo
Eccoci qua allora Vitale e arancione
oggi io Celeste anche se in realtà ho la
maglietta gialla non so di che colore
apparirà nel lì nella camera Comunque
non vedo l'ora di iniziare perché
possiamo collezionare i vari morfo dei
Rainbow Friends Io voglio prenderli
tutti
Poi voglio provare a trasformarmi Ma voi
avete lasciato un bel mi piace perché se
questo video veramente 5.000 mi piace
Proveremo altri giochi di Gameboy
Friends e scriveteci nei commenti Qual è
il vostro preferito Ehi io l'ho già
trovato uno hacker blu ho trovato Hehehe
Vieni vieni vieni qua
Anch'io anch'io
all'entrata vai
è blu dice blu ma è nero Ah perché blu è
il nome del personaggio
qui alla cassaforte viene Rita da questa
parte da questa parte e poi la cosa
bellissima che possiamo esplorare la
mappa senza l'ansia di essere presi da
sentiremo presto E qui lo vedi qui
questa armadietto vieni Ah era nascosto
benissimo
Senti ma che dici Scendiamo giù da
questo passaggio Eh ok via buttiamoci
Allora prendiamo i bottoni Qua c'è
qualche bottone verde
Vitale Chi riesce a prendere più Uhm
molto più Rainbow Friends vincente Okay
Uh ho preso verde pure io in modalità
cattiva Dopo proviamo a trasformarci
l'ho trovato un altro Oh oh oh mi sa che
per ora siamo pari però poi dall'altra
parte perché devi stare qui a copiare
tutto quello che prendo io sto cercando
Mmm con un altro Dark Green wow wow Ah a
proposito
Chiediti oggi che è solo da solo così
andiamo delle tavolozze per dipinto
Esatto le vedete che voto gli date da 1
a 10 scrivetelo nei commenti se non lo
sapete per ogni video indosserò degli
orecchini diversi voi gli date un voto
da 1 a 10 e poi vediamo chi sarà il
vincitore soprattutto che cosa gli
facciamo indossare a Vitale andiamo a
fare i buchi ah ah se questo video
raggiunge 30.000 mi piace faremo fare i
buchi alle orecchie a Vitale
apro Prova un'altra barca e anche un
altro ne ho sette già Tu quanti ne hai
che carino
Allora il mio preferito è Green perché
anche se ti prende ti stritolano se non
avete visto l'altro video non dovete
vederlo mi ha stritolato è carino con
quegli occhietti
sono sette tu ce ne hai 8 Oh aspetta non
ho capito computer Anch'io sono morto
adesso Ah ah ah Sono anche il Glitch
Green Ehi sbaglio mi stai seguendo vai
no oh oh ho ritrovato Wow a quanto sei e
11 11 12
Perfetto
Sì questa parte non l'avevo mai vista
nella mappa
e tipo c'è una stupenda Come come quando
si va a farsi divertimento bagni come i
bagni Wow Ma è fighissima questa mappa
c'è anche il teatro
bellissimo
credo che in questo gioco sia più grande
forse siamo noi che non siamo riusciti a
andare tanto avanti perché ci hanno
stritolando e poi c'è Green arancione Ah
Aiuto no aspetta aspetta non mi dire che
mi prende ah ah no no no no aspetta un
momento io credevo che in questo gioco
no no
Ah mi sto seguendo Grillo orangea Green
con un mix di Orange la casa di pace ha
fatto 6 12 ma uh ce n'è un altro 12
Ok Green arancione se n'è andato
proviamo a tornare là dentro e vediamo
se riusciamo ad esplorarli
mentre io ho esplorato Vitale se ne
approfittate trovato tutti sono 18
adesso
c'è Orange in giro sì te l'ho detto ero
troppo presto prendere i morph qui Stai
attento
blu veramente sì io qua vedo blu ma è
immobile credo che sia un pupazzo forse
non lo so come si fa scappare c'è anche
Green c'è anche Green attenzione raga
e quindi ci inseguono lo stesso
No io volevo stare tranquillo in questa
mappa è bellissimo bellissimo
credo che se ti prende spariscono tutti
adesso
Ehi Qua c'è una torta eh eh Eccomi
Dominick
sbrighiamoci
prendiamoli subito Oh c'è anche Red
Crunch
Era ora Orange ma era tipo nero Com'è
possibile che cambia colore
è cattivo no quello ci avete detto voi
Grazie nei commenti abbiamo scoperto
l'altra volta che se vediamo le mani Qua
vedete in questo
vent Eh quello è valido No è Purple Eh
mi sono inventato tutto
io ero uscito con scritto Vai ho letto
qualcosa nella morfo Eh sì perché si
mettono un sacco di colori di 18 27
[Musica]
Wow Adesso lo vado a prendere pure io
allora ho un'idea proviamo a
trasformarci in qualcosa Non lo so se ho
un'idea abbiamo visto prima erano degli
altri giocatori che sono trasformati non
lo so io non mi fiderei Allora proviamo
a trasformarci in
Gold blu ok Questo era un giocatore
trasformato
Wow
fighissimo trasformarsi in uno dei
Rainbow Friends posso anche passare qua
Wow eri tu quella lì gialla gigante!
sono dorata
dovevi evitare andiamo a prendere
proprio per
Questo invece no Ahia mi hai fatto
volare
Dimmi un'altra volta sì ho trovato un
altro eh eh eh Per il momento sono in
vantaggio io eh di poco perché io ne ho
21 E tu quanti
ah ah Ma come hai fatto a prendere così
tanto bravo ad andare in giro Aspetta
aspetta 34 cambiamo trasformazione
Voglio qualcosa di più veloce
voglio Green il mio preferito Quindi si
può essere più veloce cambiando la morfo
Non lo so vediamo allora ora mi
trasforma in routine vediamo sì Guardate
Mi sono trasformata in treno Ora andiamo
a catturare Vitale Ah ah ah ah
ah poverino Grillo dai Guardate come fai
a essere cattivo Guardate questi
occhietti troppo carini Uh pure queste
braccia stritolatrice
mi piacciono Nel frattempo io ne ho
trovati altri 3
e sono a 24
che cosa ridi perché io sono 36 ah ah li
trovate tutti questi vado in giro a
cercare
no carino questa paperella paperella
tranquillo adesso che ti trovo vengo a
prenderti da dove sei trovi trovato un
sacco qua No vabbè Guardate come sono
andate ovunque
facciamo una battaglia io ho messo Evil
Blu però c'ho la corona rossa
Quanto è carino quello come salta cioè
come fai a essere cattivo lo vorrei
abbracciare
Vediamo se qua sopra nel castello c'è
qualcosa Certo che c'è qualcosa qua ho
trovato un sacco di altri morfo dove Boh
chi si ricorda lo trovate nel dettaglio
sono 40 Ah ci puoi credere Non ci credo
stai per vincere 41 Scusa scusa scusa
sbrighiamoci Questo l'avevo preso
comunque 42 32
non riesco a passare bene quindi mi
trasformerò in ora Orange mi trasformo
in Orange elettrico ma carinissimo anche
ora Guardate la lucertolina il
coccodrillo è troppo carino Uh uh uh
uh
Moments later Uffa Ma io non trovo più
Marco si può sapere Io lo trovo più
Anita dov'è andata
sono proprio all'entrata Hai presente
dove siamo scesi Sto provando a salire
da questa scala uh uh
all'inizio ma ti ricordo che io
non ho resistito Ciao Me ne mancano solo
10 ma è possibile dove
l'hai trovato dappertutto già Allora io
ricordo il normale perché è più facile
anche qua Wow gli altri peggio dai
almeno mancano solo 10 chiamano peggio
omorfo perché nel gioco c'è morto qua
qua dice Beh peggio forse perché lui
conta i badge però i morfo poi li puoi
utilizzare No che figata
[Applauso]
questo Green tipo nero con le nuvolette
Che carino qua non sono entrato Quindi
nei bagni figo 47 oh oh ho fatto
dobbiamo aver trovato tutte quelle
amorfo Vitale perché deve andare in giro
a cercarle Allora proviamo a
trasformarci in qualcos'altro Aki wakick
aiuto cioè questo qui blu che mi sta mi
sta facendo arrotolare dappertutto eh
interessante ora vengo io ad
abbracciarti con le mie braccia ho
sentito dove sei nella stanza dei giochi
Allora siccome non trovo altre Uhm
Questa era una cosa benissimo questa
morph
forse trovo qualcos'altro qua
me ne mancano pochissimi
Sì finalmente sto trovando altre morfo
dovevo stare Ah e te l'ho detto a quanto
sei tra 307 49
finalmente stiamo trovando un sacco di
nuovi morti in quest'area erano tutte
nascoste qua ti dice che questo è il
nascondiglio di Orazio
si nasconde qua quindi
ora quando giocheremo nuovamente al
gioco ufficiale lo sapremo teatro ci
siamo già stati Uh Questo non l'avevo
preso dove niente da dire
Ah tu dici Sei già stato E certo mi sa
che ti sto raggiungendo Mi dispiace per
te 44 44
[Musica]
Uh Questa era nascosto benissimo
Mi dispiace per te Mancano solo 5 non so
più dove andare a cercare Purple blu
Guardate che carino non so perché rimane
seduto con la bava Boh comunque
Allora potremmo tornare nel teatro Ahm
Sì io sono il teatro adesso
[Musica]
dobbiamo scappare
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto perché non
riesco a prenderti Ehi torna subito qua
perché mi sono nascosto bene Oh no mi
hai fatto rotolare
bellissima per rotolare Vitale terra qua
via
viaggia altrimenti Vitale prende tempo
riuscirà a prendere più di me ma sono
cinque
non so più dove cercare
49 me ne mancano solo quattro Che bello
non vedo l'ora voglio vincere tutto devo
superare Vitale devo trovare 42 Ma dove
li stai trovando si può sapere
lucertola la lucertola quella arancione
Sì certo Orange Allora prova a
trasformarmi in quella Io ora sono magma
Orange
Che figo Oh
che belli belli tipo puoi trasformare in
un sacco di cose
ti sei trasformato mi trasforma in Green
Orange ti sembra ora così sembra un
coccodrillo
senti in cui si scontreremo a quanto sei
adesso
49 tu
52 cioè te ne Mancano pochissime volte
sicuramente è difficilissimo da trovare
perché gli ultimi tre sono super
difficili
[Musica]
solo se tu mi dici dove trovarne uno ti
dirò dove l'ho trovata no allora giammai
non vuoi fare questo scambio
Ma tu sei il rosso
sono Orange Green Mmm sembra un
lucertolone verde e tu di che colore sei
Io sono magma Green ma forse ti vedo
Dove sei
Guarda guarda
solo questo mi vedi stasera
ho deciso che ora ti seguo visto che non
ne trovate
Niente siamo in macchina
Uffa però non riesco a trovare nulla più
Guardate questo Green com'è C'è un
grillo tutto colorato l'hai visto l'ho
visto Wow Vediamo se ce l'ho come è
morto voglio provarla Sì si chiama
Glitch Green come se fossero i Glitch
dello schermo Vediamo se mi porta
fortuna in Trovare altre borse
era proprio qui davanti a me non l'avevo
trovato semplice sì Questo qui era
proprio Aspetta adesso ti dico questo
qui vicino la malacina che è presa
Pensavo fosse a pagamento questo si
prende Infatti bisogna stare attenti a
tutto tutto tutto tutto tutto Ah grazie
vitale per il suggerimento Dai dai avevo
già preso
Uffa
Sono ancora 50 e io sono 53 Beh La cosa
positiva è che io ho studiato bene la
mappa Quindi la prossima volta che
giocheremo non me la ricorderò per
niente niente
ah ah però magari invitare Te la
ricorderà
a me piace troppo questa morph da
lucertolina E coccodrilletto sì quindi
il tuo preferito è No non è un
coccodrillo
mi sembra strano che sei un coccodrillo
qui ne ho trovato uno super nascosto Non
ci posso credere ve ne manca solo uno
aspetta per vincere questo era Evil
Orange Tra l'altro Wow possiamo ancora
farcela Stories perché ci mancano
pochissimi 4 facendo molta attenzione
allora questo che ho trovato era
veramente veramente difficile
Allora 52
No questo si compra Uffa Pink Ma questo
è un nuovo personaggio si chiama Pink
Floyd
Qua c'è blu che fa la doccia
Stai attento che potrei ancora amata
1 3
Com'è che ci si abbassa Eh no purtroppo
non si abbassa Uffa però se metti una
morso piccoli più piccola riesce a
passare in alcuni Oh Grazie per il
suggerimento Allora il più piccolo è
sicuramente ora Anzi ho usato Orange per
passare mmm mmm
Ah ci sono passata non ci credo tu non
mi ascolti ma non hanno messo nessuna
mano io gli ho detto come fare per
passare fantastico
Allora comunque in realtà ora Orange mi
ricorda un personaggio Vediamo se sai
Quale Quale personaggio un personaggio
l'ho capito
quello dei sofficini
No Hahaha
Eh forse un pochino si è iscritto
quello di Monsters & Co Ve lo ricordate
si chiama così Ma quello rotondo No no
quello rotondo quello cattivo che era
tipo un camaleonte che è cambiato ancora
Hai ragione Bravissima Ma ora basta mi
sto distraendo troppo ma eri tu quella
aspetta che ti travolgo questo
si fa travolgerti Certo sei molto buffo
con questa forma te l'ho detto sempre
quello dei sofficini Hehe Alla ricerca
delle due morfo perdute
[Musica]
Sì è veramente difficilissimo
che cosa non credo di essere mai stata
in quest'area con questi tubi o forse
sono perché non ho senso
dell'orientamento
Sicuro Sicuro che non te lo ricordi
Ehi non riesco a passare da qua Ma uffa
perché sei troppo bravo
lo stesso aiuto aiuto
mio fratello aiuto ah ah dai vieni ti
dico dove sta una Guarda
No veramente vieni qui all'angolino
Guardami Vieni qua e prendi questo Evil
Orange qui ah ah vabbè hai visto sono
stato bravo ma è possibile Davvero ce ne
manca solo Wow ce ne manca solo uno a
testa adesso Wow allora Grazie per
l'indizio non so perché mi hai buttato
era nascosto super bene quindi non
l'avrei mai trovata Esatto
ora la sfida si fa ancora più a vincente
perché chi troverà l'ultimo giorno
finale vincerà la sfida
ragazzi Stiamo cercando da un sacco di
tempo non abbiamo trovato troviamo
niente Non so se è buggato noi dobbiamo
decidere di fare una cosa sì faremo un
gioco di squadra comprerò la lente per
trovare
l'ultima volta dai così vediamo
insieme e così finalmente vinceremo noi
possiamo lasciare dopo che abbiamo preso
54 Morti Non possiamo prendere l'ultima
Eh quindi poi soprattutto cosa volevo
dire non prendere questa cosa possiamo
prendere l'ultimo Okay Poi sicuramente
sarai nel posto proprio molto più
semplice ci siamo passati 10.000 volte
non l'abbiamo mai visto troppo curiosa
di vedere cos'è Cioè cos'è e dove sei
allora raggiungimi così poi ci spostiamo
assieme Ok ragazzi allora è infinito
infinito quest'ultimo corpo perché non
riesco a prendere i robot Non so perché
quindi Vitale prenderà il il la lente di
ingrandimento Quindi ora state vedendo
Vitale che gioca io lo sento come si fa
a mettere la lente d'ingrandimento però
oh no ma l'hai presa è pezzo di sì mi ha
detto Mi ha detto che ci sono riuscito
Però ti rivela solo una posizione a caso
o no E come si fa una posizione a casa
Ah ecco Guarda vedi mi sta facendo
vedere dove andare Seguitemi
tu tu tu quindi non ci rivela quello che
ci manca
Ah no Allora sei inutile Eh però visto
che ce ne manca uno magari ci ci stava
Rive proprio quello lì speriamo Ok
quindi ti appare una linea una specie di
lineetta gialla proviamo allora ti sta
portando
per lui ha indicati Allora qui Aspetta
aspetta
Ok andiamo andiamo allora Attraversiamo
di quam vediamo che cosa sarà l'ultimo e
dove sarà Mah mah Vai vai fammi salire
qua non ci credo non ci credo
55 abbiamo preso abbiamo presi tutti Wow
Avete visto dov'era nascosto come si
faceva salire qua sopra le non ci credo
abbiamo preparato anche gli altri
giocatori
Saranno felici anche loro 55 è
importante che abbiamo vinto Sì
ha lasciato un bel mi piace perché ci
sono altri giochi Rainbow Friends che
possiamo provare dovete indovinare ogni
5.000 mi piace ne Proveremo altri e ora
vi lasciamo Qua quattro caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quelle che preferite eh
Buona visione Ciao